[Yan Shuang Lindblom] Firstly, congratulations
... what was your feeling when you received
the news of being awarded the Nobel Prize
in Literature?
[Mo Yan] I feel so surprised ... when I heard
this, because I considered the Nobel Prize
in Literature to be far away from me.
[YSL] Many of Nobelprize.org's visitors are
high school students, which of your books
would be a good starting point for a young
person or newcomer to your work?
[MY] I hope readers start with my book Life
and Death are Wearing Me Out which was published
in Sweden this year.
Then read the others, such as Red Sorghum,
Big Breasts and Wide Hips and so on.
I recommend Life and Death are Wearing Me
Out first because this book reflects my writing
style relatively comprehensively, and also
my exploration on the art of novel.
[YSL] As a young man, what inspired you to
become a writer?
[MY] I started to read books when I was a
child.
This triggered my strong interest in literature
after reading more and more books.
I felt I had many words to express, I thought
the strongest and most unconstrained way was
through literature, so I started to write.
Of course, I also had a desire to prove myself,
and a wish to change my destiny.
[YSL] Could you introduce us to your creative
works?
[MY] Right now I recommended my book Life
and Death are Wearing Me Out.
Firstly this book deals with major issues
from Chinese history and reality, such as
the land issues, the farmers' issues.
Secondly, in this book I have used the oriental
surreal wording.
In this novel, the human and the animal can
switch freely, can observe the changes that
Chinese society and history have underwent
in the last 50 years, through the eyes of
the animal.
In addition, I made many attempts in my use
of language to try the most free style and
most unconstrained way to describe my ideas
from the heart.
So I think this book is a relatively perfect
and uniform combination between attention
to reality and the exploration of creative
style.
[YSL] I read that you wrote Life and Death
are Wearing me Out in 43 days, what drove
you to write so fast?
How do you find the writing process?
[MY] How I could write the novel Life and
Death are Wearing Me Out so quickly?
Firstly, this book is based on reality.
When I was of the ages 6 and 7, there was
a farmer who lived nearby our school.
He did the counterwork against the whole society,
against the "people's communes", and the "collectivization
" individually, he was insisting to the last.
At that time a person like him was considered
to be very extreme, he was considered as monster,
people carried out beatings and abuse towards
him.
He made huge sacrifices in order to insist
upon his own opinion.
His family, including his son and daughter,
parted way from him and were separated from
him, but he still would not yield.
Later on, history proved that he had been
right.
After I embarked on writing the novel, I felt
this guy would go into it sooner or later,
so this book was written very quickly.
I spent only 43 days writing the draft, but
in fact the novel's characters had already
existed in my mind for many decades.
The thinking was very adequate, so the writing
was fast.
[YSL] How are you going to celebrate and are
you coming to Sweden for the award ceremony?
[MY] I think I will be with my family tomorrow
and eat dumplings, because I hope we can eat
dumplings together.
I will also certainly come to Sweden on 10
December for the Nobel Prize Award Ceremony.
Thanks very much!
And see you in Sweden!